with you level with the the british
public
more families many more families are
going to lose
loved ones before their time i must give
the british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
there was no large-scale scale um
removal of people from hospital into
care homes
towards the start of this crisis every
year in seasonal
flu the number of deaths is thought to
be about 8 000
excess deaths so if we can get this down
to numbers
20 000 and below that's a
good outcome in terms of where we would
hope to get to with this outbreak
christmas is going to be
different this year perhaps very
different it's been
it's been such a tough year for so many
people and
um finally we have our our way through
it our
um our light at the end of the tunnel
this is not the natural peak that's
going to come
down on its own it's coming down because
of the measures that are in place
take the lid off now this is going to
boil over for sure and we'll end up with
a big problem
[Applause]
very pleased to say that joining us now
to answer your questions
the government's chief scientific
advisor at sir patrick valance
sir patrick very good to see you this
morning um
plenty to get through but let's begin
with the thing that we all hope
will be our way out of the pandemic the
vaccines
[Applause]
our first question at this morning at
sir patrick is from
tony tony henley let's hear from tony
hello my question for sir patrick is
this
with the huge amount of people that have
had kobe 19 in the past year and
survived
and therefore gained some kind of
immunity how many people do you believe
need vaccinating before the government
can allow
restrictions to be removed at least
slightly
that's sir what level of vaccination
required before we see those
restrictions
i mean the first thing to say is as the
question
says there's been huge numbers of cases
and
uh the nhs is under enormous pressure at
the moment and i do want to start by
just
again reiterating how grateful i am and
i think we all
are to the people in the nhs working so
hard to try and
keep this under control to make sure
that people get the care they need it's
very difficult
it may not look like it when you go for
a walk in the park but when you go into
a hospital
this is very very bad at the moment with
enormous pressure and in some cases it
looks like a war zone in terms of
the things that people are having to
deal with so it's true that lots of
people have had the disease
but it's worth remembering that when we
say that
we're talking about something like one
in eight so
it's not a very high percentage of the
total population
in terms of the numbers of people that
would need vaccination it's worth just
understanding
what the vaccines will do so the first
thing the vaccines will do
is protect those people who've had the
vaccine
from severe illness and reduce the
chance of dying from the disease so it's
an individual protection
and a second leg if i can just
that we know much less about the ability
of the vaccine to stop
transmission we think it will stop
transmission but we don't know by how
much yet
and you'll need very very high levels of
population coverage 70 percent or more
in order to get some degree of immunity
across the whole population
um uh so patrick our second question is
from
philip dunn morning philip and it's an
interesting one israel he says
has done some clinical trials they
dispute
the uk's claim of 89 efficacy after the
first dose of the fires of vaccine they
say
at more like 33 percent uh what do you
think
well i think that what i'll tell you
what we know and what we don't know
so so what we know from the clinical
studies particularly i'll talk about the
the fisa vaccine here is that if you
take
everything from day zeros the moment you
get the vaccine to
day 28 then the overall figure is
something like 50
protection but of course you don't
expect to get any protection in the
first 10 days
because it hasn't had a chance for the
immune system to build up and
uh some people may have been infected
before they had the vaccine so if you
take from day 10
up towards day 21 and beyond then
it looks much more like the 89 figure
that the
jcbi the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
said so that's the clinical trial data
and we also know that when you get into
real world practice
things are seldom quite as good as
clinical trials so i think the 89
or so is the figure that you see post 10
days
so that's the basis of the
recommendation um it probably won't be
as high as that in practice but i don't
think it'll be
uh as low um as as the figures you've
just given
i don't know exactly what israel are
looking at they're looking at the total
period from day
north then that that doesn't give uh the
reasons i've said an exact comparison
but we need to look at this very
carefully i mean we just we just need to
keep measuring and understanding it
we're just just sticking with that point
then when will we know
the kind of the the degree of efficacy
well i think we'll get information from
israel we'll get information from us
we'll see what's happening in the real
world
um and we should expect to see more data
on that over the next
the next few weeks and as i say it's
quite important not to assume this
protects in the first 10 days because it
doesn't
and so the first 10 days you'll expect
to see infections from people who
already infected or
got infection after the vaccine it's
only after that the protection
starts to kick in and we should start
seeing more data on this over the next
few weeks to get a better handle on
exactly how effective this is in the
real world rather than in the conditions
of a clinical trial
run from bexley heath gets in touch with
the question again about the divisor of
action he says this uh i should very
much like to gain an assurance from sir
patrick
and that all those who have had the
first dose of the covert vaccine in my
case the pfizer
that they will receive their second dose
before
12 weeks has elapsed can you provide
that assurance to patrick
well i certainly can't provide assurance
because i'm not in charge of delivering
vaccines but i know what the plan is and
the plan is absolutely that people
should
get their second dose in the 12-week
period that's what everything's set up
to deliver and that's the aim of the
programme
um our next question from roshan
raghavan day
their question why have black asian
and ethnic minority groups not been made
a priority group
for the vaccine despite the huge numbers
who have died and
all the previous discussions about how
people from these groups are are far
more likely to die from this virus
prioritization is clearly
a a problem a difficult problem to
grapple with but but the data does
suggest
uh that being people might need to be
prioritized soon
yeah i i think look the the there's a
tragedy and
the tragedy is is relating to inequality
and it's also relating to black asian
minority ethnic groups where we know
there's an increased risk
for sure and um the prioritization that
the jcvi has done
has been based on the highest risk and
the highest risk factor for this is
age so the reason that this has been
done as it has been done
is absolutely based on the evidence of
what the highest risk is so get the over
80 year olds vaccinated first those in
health
in care homes the people are caring for
them because that's how
it spreads and then come down the age
range
i think it's crucial and this is really
really important
that as we do that very special care is
taken
to make sure that those groups that have
been mentioned
are targeted to come forward to make
sure that we get people vaccinated
it's really important that group gets
vaccinated then as you get down the age
groups
and you get down towards the 50 year
olds in due course that's when
jcvi and others will have to look about
what the other criteria are that need to
be taken into account but i think my
message today
is everybody in the age groups that is
eligible for vaccine
should go and get a vaccine incredibly
important
encourage your relatives to do it
encourage those who need it to go out
and get it
and particularly we need to really offer
the support and understanding
um for those groups who might be
hesitant or might not understand the
need or might not believe that there's a
need for this
and so i think a real campaign to make
sure we reach
those harder to reach groups is crucial
if we're going to get on top of this
um denise o'sullivan in north london is
perhaps speaking for a few people this
morning when she asks this um
are we going to have periods every year
where we will have to lock down again
because an old version of the vaccine is
running out and
people have not yet received their
yearly top up
do you conceive of of us coming out of
this completely anytime soon i mean
it feels like we've been in out in out
shaking it all about in terms of
lockdowns uh well let me do with a
vaccine question first of all
i think it's quite likely that we are
going to need regular vaccination
at least for a few years um and i think
it's quite likely that those vaccines
may need to change a bit
as they do for flu every year so i think
that's quite likely that we're going to
have to have some
annual or maybe every two-year
vaccination we don't know yet and
that may change but that will be planned
in the way it's planned for
uh flu as well um i think coming
this winter um you know a lot will be
better
because the vaccination will have been
rolled out across a very large
proportions of of of society
um and uh hopefully if we can really
bring the numbers down now
and we test and trace and isolate system
in a much better place
that will lead us into a much better
position in the summer and then going
into
next winter um as chris whittier said um
as well i don't think that we can assume
that there won't be anything needed next
winter now
you know it's more likely to be making
sure that we wear masks in certain
places making sure that we keep up with
hand washing
making sure that we're sensible about
the way in which we interact with people
in indoor environments
that's the sort of thing that you might
anticipate but you know this virus has
taken us by surprise time and time again
and we just don't know i'd be very
surprised if we go in year on year with
needing to do things uh
more than that um but this win this you
know
coming winter i think we need to wait
and see how how far we get on with
with the um current current reduction in
numbers that needs to occur
well let's move on now uh appropriate
enough in fact given what you've just
been saying to take a look
at lockdown and coronavirus restrictions
i mean sir patrick you will be as aware
as anyone that there has been a degree
of
of skepticism around at face masks uh
joe quinn living
asked the question just how much
protection
do face masks actually offer us
well this is still um something of a of
an unknown to put an exact number on it
what i think is
is clear is that face masks
are most effective at preventing
spread from the person wearing them so
they're useful to stop
people who might not know they have the
disease who may be of course
asymptomatic because you shouldn't be
out and about anyway if you've got the
uh symptoms but asymptomatic people from
spreading from
um releasing it towards others so that's
where they're most effective they have
some effect preventing
you from catching it from others as well
it's not the biggest effect so i mean
it's important and we do need to do it
and
every little counts in terms of making
sure that we get on top of this
but we can't put an exact number on it
so face masks are an important part of
this they're important in conditions
where you're going to be
potentially with other people from that
you don't normally mix with
important where you're in indoor
environments where the spread is greater
important where there's crowding and
they will be an important part of
managing this
uh this going forward and it's worth
just saying that
you know we look at vaccines which are
going to be so important in the long run
vaccines are not going to get the
numbers under control now
the things that are going to get the
are hand hygiene keeping distance
not socializing staying at home wearing
masks when you're in
situations where you have to be out
these are the things that are going to
keep the numbers down now
and the things we absolutely need to
focus on because numbers are
very high still um a related question
then uh
from michael lim he's asking this when
is the uk
going to make the wearing of masks
mandatory
when outside michael asserts that this
has been proven to be very effective in
preventing the spread of the virus
is that something that's under
consideration well i think the advice
that we've given obviously these are
decisions
for ministers the advice we've given is
that face masks
are most useful in indoor environments
mixing with people you don't
uh don't normally mix with they can be
useful in outdoor environments where
there's crowding but frankly they
shouldn't be crowding so that's the
thing to try and get on top of
um probably of no value in terms of just
being outside generally where there's
not
any crowding or were you just passing
somebody for a second but they
may have a role in outdoor environments
you one might think of something like an
outdoor market where there's crowding
that is somewhere where i think people
should wear
should wear uh face coverings but i say
the really key thing is avoid crowding i
mean we've got to try and stop
people from having contacts we've got to
ourselves take responsibility
and i will say that i think the vast
majority of people
are really doing a great job of taking
this seriously and making sure that we
follow the rules and that's the key
thing we're in this together and we have
to make sure we all
do it because we're protecting each
other um of course
lots of us over the course of
coronavirus have have struggled to see
older relatives for those who have
older relatives in care homes it has
been even more even more difficult holly
bentley asked this question
and with a dose of a vaccine ppe
and use of lateral flow testing do you
feel it is relatively safe
for indoor care home visits if not would
you feel it's relatively safe
with all of the above and two doses of
the vaccine
this is a horrible situation and you
know many of us have got relatives who
are in care homes and how difficult it
is not to be able to see them and not to
be able to do the things that we all
wish to do the normal human things
but i'm afraid my answer to this
question is no it's not
safe and we have to know that with the
levels of infection
as they are at the moment we have to
stick to the
rules to get the levels down and that
means
not jumping the gun and although one
dose of vaccine
is protecting individuals who've had it
from
serious disease and consequences
including death
being reduced in them it doesn't stop
spread
at least we don't know by how much it
stops spread and so
i think this is not the time to be
relaxing any measures at all i'm afraid
and care homes have got done a good job
of getting rules in place
working with the directors of local
directors of public health
to make sure they try and create the
safest environment they can
and we have to stick with that for a bit
longer however difficult however
personally um challenging that is i'm
afraid that is what we need to do at the
moment
sure given given what you've just said
is there
any hope that a trip to a care home
would be safe
before not just community transmission
has been
has been stopped as plateaued but until
you know community infection is
way way down i i think we're still going
it's still going to be tricky until
community infection comes down a lot
further than it is now i mean we're at
high levels
the measures that are in place and this
is important i mean the measures are in
place
are making a difference you can see that
um levels are
flattening in some places in some places
maybe coming down a bit and other places
still rising a bit but more slowly
but we're at really high levels i mean
something like 1 in 55
people infected higher in many areas the
prospect of spread is still high and i'm
afraid this is
absolutely not the time to be talking
about relaxing
measures and the vaccine rollout is
critical
we've got to get on top of that but
we're not there yet we're at the early
stages of that
um you know it's great that over 50
percent of
the over 80s are now vaccinated and a
high proportion of people in care homes
but we haven't got far enough yet and i
think it's just too early to be doing
this
and we risk uh the whole thing uh
flaring up
um peter ark sent in this uh next
question but i think from what you've
said
we might know the answer he asks will
the government keep the lockdown going
for longer
if the figures do not come down and how
long will it continue
if they do i wonder if you can answer
peter bearing in mind of course as you
have said a few times this morning
these are decisions for politicians you
merely provide the advice
what would the advice be well the advice
at the moment is uh you know
vaccines are not going to do the heavy
lifting for us at the moment anywhere
near it this is about i'm afraid the
restrictive measures which we're all
living
under and carrying on with those and the
numbers are nowhere near where they need
to be at the moment they need to come
down quite a lot further we need to make
sure we stick with it
um i'll reiterate something i said at
the beginning and you go for a walk in
the park or something life looks normal
you go for a walk in a hospital if you
work in a hospital you will see life not
looking normal at all this is a
really difficult dangerous situation
we're in and we need to get the numbers
down so i don't see
a release of these measures as being a
sensible thing to do
in the short term clearly you know one
hopes that as
uh as the numbers do come down with the
measures and as the vaccine takes hold
it would be possible to start a gradual
release of some of the
measures but i think it's important to
recognize this is not going to be a sort
of big bang
great take the lid off everything's fine
we can all go back to normal this is
going to be a slow release
monitoring carefully understanding the
effects
uh next up actually just a few questions
asking
whether or not the uk could have handled
some parts of this
pandemic better
starting with david mccormick from
doncaster he centers this question
if you could head back to march 2020
what measures would you recommend to the
government knowing then
what you know now yeah it's a great
question and you know we will have got
some things right and something's wrong
and
and we've learned a lot uh as we've gone
through this and we know a lot more
about the virus today than we did then
for sure
i think there is a a very simple uh
series of uh
recommendations which you know i've been
pushing uh continuously and i'll
continue to do so which is
uh the lesson is go earlier than you
think you want to
go a bit harder than you think you want
to and go a bit broader than you think
you want to
in terms of applying the restrictions
i'm afraid that's a grim message but
that is what the evidence says
you've got to go hard early
and broader if you're going to get on
top of this waiting and watching
simply doesn't work and the second thing
i'd say
is that um you know if you go right back
and this is
obviously much easier with the benefit
of hindsight you go back to january
the things that that might have um uh
have been effective
but i don't think anyone at the time
would have really thought of
of doing this or been able to apply this
we know that we got importation of cases
and so i think stricter measures in
terms of making sure that people come in
quarantine and so on are important
um to stop importation of cases we're
seeing that now with the variant trying
to
trying to delay importation of cases i
think those are measures which are
quite important and but they have to go
very early um
you know by the time you're in march um
we had so many cases in the uk
i don't think that would have made any
difference at that time
i'm just just just on that on that point
um
clearly you sir chris whitty
chris whitty any number of politicians
have been on the the steepest of
learning
learning curves when it comes to covert
19 identifying and then
and then learning from the mistakes but
because the government strategy that
the public health strategy has had to
change from time to time
would you accept that there have on
occasion
been problems with communicating that
strategy
yeah i'm sure they have i mean i mean
you know it it's difficult and
and things are changing and uh rules
have been changed and and i'm sure lots
of lessons have been learned on the
communication side as on other side i
mean this is this is an unparalleled
situation it would be completely
astonishing if everything
had been done perfectly and i think you
look back and you can see situations
where
clearer communications would have helped
uh better reach to certain groups would
have helped and so on so i think i think
that's
that that's certainly the case and the
other thing that's worth bearing in mind
i think it's important is that
you know there are people who um um
perpetually want to sort of release
things sooner
perpetually don't want to go into
lockdown argue that
nothing's going to happen there isn't
going to be a second wave or there isn't
going to be another
increase um and i think this causes
quite a lot of confusion
in the public debate and it's worth
remembering the
uh the um definition of insanity by
einstein which is
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting for a different outcome and i
think the lesson is every time you
release it too quickly you get enough
you get an upswing and you can see that
right the way across the world i mean
you've got to be consistent with this
stuff
um finally sir patrick let's do what all
scientists love doing and get out the
crystal ball
and have a quick look into the future
but specifically of course
uh the future of the pandemic uh our
first question comes
in video form from abid salmon let's
have a listen
once the whole country is vaccinated
around the summer if
a new variant enters the uk from
overseas and doesn't work against the
vaccine
will the whole population need to be
vaccinated again from scratch
and if so how long will it take
a new variant demanding a new vaccine
your thoughts well first of all on the
on the very
the was first identified in kent i think
i think we're increasingly of the view
that that variant will be susceptible to
the vaccine and to previous immunity
um the studies are all pointing that
direction so i think that's that's
good in terms of vaccine effect um for
some of the others
that are popping up around the world and
they will continue to pop up
um we still got some question marks as
to how effective um
a vaccine will be um and those studies
need to be
um continued and as i said earlier i
think it's likely that we will need to
have modified vaccines in due course i
think that will be something that's
going to be a regular feature of this
unfortunately
the new vaccine technologies
particularly the messenger rna vaccines
um are relatively easy to change so you
can sort of almost dial up a change it
then takes a few weeks obviously for
that to be made and to come through so
it's not instantaneous
but i think that's that's what we're
going to see so i wouldn't be at all
surprised if
time to time we need to get slight
variations of the vaccines in order to
make sure that we um
keep on top of this and i think um
changes in the virus will occur all over
the world i mean
the viruses mutate that's what they do
and i would expect to see
more of that as we go forward um do you
great news of course about about the
british variant of the
variant of covid19 but i wondered
reading between the lines of what you
were saying there whether you've seen
the same research that i have
about the south african variant and and
the potential that that
is it does not enjoy the same level of
efficacy
in terms of the vaccine well so at the
moment what we've got is some laboratory
studies and some predictions
which suggest that this may uh be a
virus that can
um escape some of the immune effects of
of antibodies we don't know
to what degree so it's quite difficult
to interpret those laboratory studies in
terms of the clinical effect that we'll
have
we should get information on the
clinical effects because vaccinations
occurring in
south africa or it's occurring in brazil
it's occurring in other places where
variants may occur so we should get some
information on that
they are more worrying in the sense that
they are a little bit
more different in terms of how the
immune system may recognize them so we
you know it's a real issue of concern
it's something that we need to keep an
eye on but we don't have all the answers
yet
and i would just caution about you know
the laboratory studies are
not perfect predictors of what happens
in the clinic so we need to
get clinical data as soon as we can um
final question from the public uh simone
sheffield asking this with the vaccine
rollout in progress
and individuals gaining natural immunity
natural resistance
from actually having the virus at what
point does the combination of these
factors mean the uk
reaches herd immunity
well total herd immunity and you know we
may not get to actually perfect herd
immunity
with vaccines but you're probably going
to need 70
plus of the population to be immune for
for that to occur
but every degree of immunity in the
population makes it more difficult for
the virus to spread
makes it a bit easier for things to
return to normal so i don't think it's
an absolute but total herd immunity is
going to require very high levels of
vaccine cover um as i said what we're
trying to do at the moment is protect
the most
uh most most vulnerable um
sir patrick our last set of questions
comes from mr
n patterson in this studio in
westminster i
just got to wonder how have you been
doing through all of this we we look at
our politicians we look at our
scientific advisors our chief medical
officers
you know you've been burning the
midnight oil the candle at both ends
are you coping well i hope i'm coping um
the the uh as always you know there are
people having it much tougher than i am
for sure and you know again look at the
nhs staff and what they're going through
at the moment and actually i look at
people like um
um uh uh small business owners who are
suffering you know they've got really
tough times
my son's a teacher you know people
people everyone's got difficult things
to deal with and yes things
things things aren't easy but um you
know i'm fortunate i have a very strong
support network uh
got strong support that work strong
support at home and
um this is about staying absolutely
focused on the
science and making sure that we uh try
and give the best possible advice that
we can
to enable the government to make these
really really difficult decisions that
they have to make
and on that of course we've said we've
both said it a few times you know
your job is to advise your job is not to
make the decisions
but how comfortable has it been for a
scientist like yourself
to kind of see the venn diagram of
science and politics kind of coming
together just a little bit more than
perhaps it might have in the past
well i mean first of all i i quite
welcome the fact that science is there
in form in government that's what we
should do in all sorts of areas and not
just here
um but you know there'll be times when
politicians need to make decisions based
on other factors and that's why you know
we have a democracy that's why they're
elected and those are the difficult
decisions they have to make
my job is to make absolutely sure that
they understand what the science advice
is and to give it
straight fearlessly and um
and even if it's unpopular or not one
that they want to hear i'm afraid they
have to hear it and then they
need to make the decisions that they
need to make and you know it's tough
um and a final word from you just just
direct to the public
if you had three sentences in which
uh to kind of instruct them to guide
them this morning as to to
what's going on right now and where we
are going what would you say
to the great british public ah there's
light at the end of the tunnel i mean
science is going to get us out of this
and we're on the way
but we need to carry on doing what we're
doing and a big thank you to everybody i
mean it's really tough to keep these
restrictions in place it's really tough
on children it's really tough on all of
us
please keep going because if we can keep
this
under control if we can drive these
numbers down
that's what's going to get us out of
this sooner that's what's going to allow
the vaccines to take effect and have the
consequences that we want and that's
what's going to allow us ultimately to
open up
sir patrick it it is rare indeed that i
get this length of time to put questions
uh to a politician
it is certainly never happened that i
have received as many straight answers
uh from them and sir patrick vance we
really do appreciate the time you've
taken
uh to answer our viewers question this
morning thank you so much for joining us
on the program
thank you let's get a little bit
announced
now to that viewer q in a uh with sir
patrick
our resident experts are joining us in
just a moment uh we'll be speaking
uh about the interview with our
technology correspondent roland manthop
and our political correspondent uh joe
pike will be
joining us in just a second as well
uh but as well as those two we've
assembled a panel of experts to explain
the significance
of what sir patrick said in a few
moments time i'll be speaking to
professor callum semple from sage
professor jeffrey hammond from the
university of oxford
dr daniel brydon from the faculty of
intensive care medicine
and dr nisserine alwyn professor of
public health they will be up in just a
second
but of course one commonly asked
question that we put to sir patrick
is whether we will need regular social
distancing restrictions in future years
and whether or not we will be needing
annual coronavirus injections he told me
that our lives are going to be changed
forever
i think it's quite likely that we are
going to need regular vaccination
at least for a few years and i think
it's quite likely that those vaccines
may need to change a bit
as they do for flu every year so i think
that's quite likely that we're going to
have to have some
annual or maybe every two year
vaccination we don't know yet and
that may change but that will be planned
in the way it's planned for uh flu as
well
um i think coming this winter um
you know a lot will be better because
the vaccination will have been rolled
out across
a very large proportions of of of
society and uh
hopefully if we can really bring the
numbers down now
and we test and trace and isolate system
in a much better place
that will lead us into a much better
position in the summer and then going
into
next winter as chris whittier said
um as well i don't think that we can
assume that there won't be anything
needed next winter
now you know it's more likely to be
making sure that we wear masks in
certain places making sure that we keep
up with
hand washing making sure that we're
sensible about the way in which we
interact with people in indoor
environments
that's the sort of thing you might
anticipate but you know this virus has
taken us by surprise time and time again
and we just don't know
now let's bring in our technology
correspondent at roland manthop first um
roland if you're looking for a dose of
cold hard reality it's the scientists
that often provide it
yeah and indeed they do and i mean sir
patrick valance said
right at the end there's light at the
end of the tunnel
but listening to him you did get the
impression that the tunnel is pretty
long
and that even once we're out of it the
road might carry on after that
he was very very clear that vaccines
are not the answer right now they're not
going to bring all these cases down
they're not going to get people out of
hospital
and he was quite clear i think that
vaccines are not the answer
in general they're not going to cure the
coronavis they're not going to stop it
dead in its tracks to use a perhaps
inappropriate phase
and that is because he said that the
data tends to show
that it doesn't stop spread it doesn't
stop transmission
so in other words is that even though
you might be protected from serious
illness which is absolutely great
you can still catch coronavirus and you
can still
pass it on and that raises questions for
how it will be
kind of spreading in the community it
raises questions
could we see a fourth wave could we see
another lockdown and well obviously he
was hopeful
saying if we all follow the guidance if
test and trace works then that might not
happen
he didn't exactly rule it out so
yes it was a cold hard dose of reality
there really
ah thanks for the moment roland uh we
also asked uh
sir patrick oh and yeah sorry we also
asked sir patrick
about what he had learned from the last
10 months of the pandemic and how he
would advise
the government to act in future
pandemics but before we move on to all
of that just just
just in terms of what we were hearing
about the vaccines the the different
variants that are out there some some
positive news certainly in terms of
the british variant but yeah it did
appear that sir patrick had seen the
same research that i had the south
african variant
in terms of whether or not the vaccine
will work starting perhaps look a little
bit more at dubious
yes exactly i i mean in in general you
know
we we have kind of fortnightly briefings
with sir patrick and
he's he's he's cautious he takes a
scientific approach
he wants to see more data but he he has
seen that research on the south african
variant and it is a little concerning
and then he and he talked about that how
we might need not only to have
regular vaccinations every winter but
also that we'll need to keep
changing the vaccine every winter just
like we do with flu i mean we can hope
that it becomes more
regular in the way that flu does but of
course as we know
flu kills many many many thousands of
people a year
so patrick also reflects that i thought
very interestingly on the latest data
that we've seen
out of israel our colleague mark stone
was reporting yesterday that the israeli
authorities
are a little bit dubious about the 89
efficacy figure that we've been given
and so patrick has given on
the for if you get just the first dose
of the pfizer vaccine
but but again on that sir patrick
essentially said
we just need to wait for more data the
israeli data comes from 14 days
he's looking at the data from 10 to 21
days and as you can see that's what he
said we should watch out for
if you take everything from day zeros
the moment you get the vaccine to
day 28 then the overall figure is
something like 50
protection but of course you don't
expect to get any protection in the
first 10 days because it hasn't had a
chance for the immune system to build up
and uh some people may have been
infected before they had the vaccine so
if you take from day 10
up towards day 21 and beyond then it
looks much more like
the 89 figure that the jcbi the joint
committee on vaccination
than immunization said so that's the
clinical trial data
and we also know that when you get into
real world practice things are seldom
quite as good as clinical trials so
i think the 89 or so is the figure that
you see
post 10 days so that's the basis of the
recommendation
um it probably won't be as high as that
in practice but i don't think it'll be
uh as low um as as the figures you've
just given
i don't know exactly what israel are
looking at they're looking at the total
period from day
north then that that doesn't give uh the
reasons i've said an exact comparison
but we need to look at this very
carefully i mean we just we just need to
keep measuring and understanding it
yes i mean you heard again sir patrick
say we need to look at this very
carefully
we're waiting for more data i i think
just stepping back a little bit
that's a reminder it's easy to think oh
we've got the vaccine we're there
we're not there we're still in the
middle of a live experiment
and we are gathering data and the
scientists are gathering data and we're
going to have to keep learning
as we go i mean we should never forget
shouldn't we that you know
viruses do mutate there are new
variations that crop up quite regularly
and that in fact if you're looking for
mutations to take place well they
tend to take places they tend to take
place in in areas where you have
significant numbers of cases
yes exactly and that is an another
reason i mean you heard him reflecting
more generally on the
on the course of the epidemic you want
to go hard you want to go early and you
want to really lock down this is another
reason why you might want to lock down
and try and keep going as long as
possible
because that stops mutations popping up
of course the difficulty is that i mean
there are thousands tens of thousands i
think
maybe about 12 000 mutations that have
been tracked so far
but we have already seen that one the
british variant
i mean it's completely transformed the
pandemic 30 to 70 percent
more transmissible there are hardly any
countries in the world that can keep it
under control even places like germany
and and he was asked about new variants
and the possibilities of new ones
popping up because
incredibly the british variant isn't
even as we call it the the one we've got
here isn't even the thing we're worried
about the thing we're really worried
about
is that a new mutation might pop up that
escapes the vaccine or escapes immunity
and he he was asked about that and i
thought he had some interesting
reflections
on the on the very that was first
identified in kent i think i think we're
increasingly of the view that that
variant will be susceptible to the
vaccine and to previous immunity
um the studies are all pointing that
direction so i think that's
that's good in terms of vaccine effect
um for some of the others
uh that are popping up around the world
and they will continue to pop up
um we still got some question marks as
to how effective um
a vaccine will be um and those studies
need to be
um uh continued and as i said earlier i
think it's likely that we will need to
have modified vaccines in due course um
i think that will be something that's
going to be a regular feature of this
yeah i mean we're going to need more
vaccines we're going to
i need to keep more monitoring it is
possible he said
that some vaccines might some viruses
might escape the vaccine
so yes lots of cold hard reality for us
there in terms of how long this is going
on
but also i think a message of hope as he
said science
can deal with this science and patrick
vance
is first and foremost a science science
is on the case
certainly is roland thanks very much
indeed
well we also asked sir patrick about
what he had learnt
from the last 10 months of the pandemic
and how he'd advise the government to
act in future outbreaks
i think there is a a very simple series
of
recommendations which you know i've been
pushing uh continuously and i'll
continue to do so which is
uh the lesson is go earlier than you
think you want to
go a bit harder than you think you want
to and go a bit broader than you think
you want to
in terms of applying the restrictions
i'm afraid that's a grim message but
that is what the evidence says
you've got to go hard early
and broader if you're going to get on
top of this waiting and watching
simply doesn't work
our political correspondent joe pike uh
joins us once again um there will be
those who listen to those comments from
the chief scientific advisor saying you
know you've got to go harder you've got
to go broader you've got to go earlier
and viewing them perhaps as a kodi
criticism of the government
certainly they sort of ally with what
kia stammer has been
saying in his critiques over the last
few months of course what's fascinating
about this is that politicians don't
really
want to look back certainly the
government at the moment don't want to
look back at
earlier stages of the pandemic and
assess what they did
right and what they did wrong although
boris johnson has sort of said something
not dissimilar to sir patrick in the
sense that some things have gone right
and some things
have gone wrong but to use this uh
language saying
earlier harder broader is the way to go
it almost i think
implies that some of the decisions have
not exactly fitted
in with that of course so patrick
balance is the chief scientific advisor
advisor's advice he's ultimately
not the person making the decision but
i'm sure we'll get a better idea of what
advice was given and whether the
decisions the government and boris
johnson made follow that
followed that in a public inquiry that
will happen
at some stage and i'm sure it could be
very difficult for many of those
involved especially considering sir
patrick famously said
that 20 000 deaths in the pandora would
be quotes
a good outcome of course we are now
careering towards maybe a hundred
thousand deaths it was also interesting
to hear this key message we've heard
from scientists about the danger
dangerous moment we are at just because
there is positive news
about the vaccine that does not mean
that hospitals
are in a positive place and in fact the
words
that patrick used to describe the state
in some hospitals was really uh i think
interesting
it may not look like it when you go for
a walk in the park but when you go into
a hospital
this is very very bad at the moment with
enormous pressure and in some cases it
looks like a war zone in terms of
the things that people are having to
deal with so it's true that lots of
people have had the disease
but it's worth remembering that when we
say that
we're talking about something like one
in eight so
it's not a very high percentage of the
total population
the chief scientific advisor saying that
some hospitals are currently like
war zones it's no coincidence that
cameras from sky news and other
broadcasters have been let into
some awards intensive care awards in the
last week or so the government
want us to see the pictures they want us
to see quite how bad it is they don't
want people just to see the positive
news
about vaccines and change our behavior
of course this
nil fits with the core message of
compliance sticking to the rules and
staying at home
i'm joe clearly as we've been reporting
on since the pandemic began care homes
have been pretty badly hit
by covid19 what more did we learn from
sir patrick
as regards you know the opportunities
available to people to get into these
care homes
to see their older relatives well not
particularly good news
on that point neil a pretty uh
pessimistic message really from sir
patrick there clearly are
people who have relatives in care homes
and desperate to visit them and visit
them ideally
inside and want to do that soon
especially if they've not seen a loved
one for
almost a year but the chief scientific
advisor was clear that does not seem to
be possible
anytime soon it's not safe
and um we have to know that with the
levels of infection
as they are at the moment we have to
stick to the
rules to get the levels down and that
means
uh not jumping the gun and although
one dose of vaccine is protecting
individuals who've had it from serious
disease and
consequences including death being
reduced in them
it doesn't stop spread at least we don't
know by how much it stops spread
and so i think this is not the time to
be relaxing any measures at all
but my top headline i think from that
fascinating half hour
interviewing question and answer session
neil was on regrets on looking back
said patrick valencia implying pretty
heavily
that the government didn't move far
enough fast enough
joe thank you time though to find out
what our panel of experts
uh made of the chief scientific
officer's answers to your question
uh we're joined now by professor callum
semple
an expert in outbreak medicine at the
university of liverpool and a member of
sage and navtag jeffrey armand a
professor in microbiology at the
university of oxford
and an advisor to the government's
vaccine task force he was also
head of research at vaccine producer
sanofi pasteur
dr daniel brydon is the vice dean of the
faculty of intensive care medicine and a
consultant at chefing teaching hospitals
and dr nasrin arwan an associate
professor of public health at the
university of
southampton um if i get ill i'm in good
company this morning
let's turn first and foremost uh to uh
professor
semple uh joining us up from liverpool
this morning professor simple good to
have you
good to have you on um i wonder what you
made um
of the statement from sir patrick that
you know covered restrictions
are likely to be needed in some form
next winter
i'm an independent member of sage and
i'm speaking independently
but i would like to say that i think
this is a fair and honest representation
of the state of where we are at present
one in eight to one in ten people have
had this illness
and although we have vaccinated the the
most very susceptible people
there are a large number of people us
we're talking
perhaps 80 to 90 percent of the
population is still susceptible
to getting severe disease that would
cause hospitalization
and put them at risk of long covered so
i completely agree
this is not the time to relax i will
certainly do
and again on that point professor sample
when when when we hear from
uh sir patrick valance that the vaccine
is not going to be doing the heavy
lifting
at the moment i mean anyone who suggests
that we are going to be seeing an
easing of restrictions a substantial
easing of restrictions
anytime soon is probably on hiding to
nothing
that's right i think where i think the
messaging
has not perhaps been even more honest
would be to say that if we don't protect
the nhs
what are the net structures in society
that will be badly affected
and here we're talking about the ability
of the fire brigade to act responsibly
the uh police to act responsibly and
potentially
ambulances as well now we already have
ambulances in some parts of the country
been driven by policemen so that gives
you an idea that
it's not just the nhs we're talking
about supporting here levels of sickness
within society as a whole if left
unchecked would rise
and cause greater problems in society
and professor simple masks have been
with us since the very beginning of all
of this and at times
you know there have been a number of
people who have been you know concerned
about their efficacy or
or otherwise i mean we had uh from the
chief scientific advisor that yep they
are
most useful in indoor environments of
very little use
if you're outdoors but not in a crowd
that's right and i think masks is one of
the areas where perhaps we as advisors
got it wrong
to start with we didn't appreciate the
importance of masks
in protecting other people we were
focused on masks in protecting the
individual wearer
and now that we've got a better
understanding that the virus is
effectively airborne in fine aerosol
form in close proximity and particularly
inside
we now understand the value of masks in
protecting
other people and yes outside where
you've got fresh air
a bit of wind air movement some
ultraviolet light
under these circumstances the mass
become uh essentially not
as effective because other factors are
controlling the virus within the
environment
good point um let's bring in dr nissarin
arwan associate professor of public
health at the
university of southampton um doctor i
went
we were talking about it with our
political correspondent joel pike just a
second ago but i'm sure many people's
attention will have focused on the words
that we had at the end of that interview
you know go earlier go harder go broader
than you think you want to is it the
case in your opinion
that on all three of those points you
know we didn't do that we didn't go
early enough
we didn't go hard enough we didn't go
broad enough and that is why we are
where we are today
absolutely yes um i agree with her with
that
um totally and i think um we're not out
of it yet
so now is the time to say we've got this
lesson we need to learn from it
um you know in at the moment in time
we're at in the pandemic
um you know so so so i think you know we
really need to understand i think a lot
of your viewers will want to know
what is the plan when we come out of the
lockdown or even when the restrictions
are a bit
uh you know relaxed so so that period
between march and september
when most of the population um are still
unvaccinated
what are we doing you know in terms of
trying to keep the
infection levels down um you know we
need
i think everybody needs to see a plan um
and
um you know how basically you know to to
know how we learned uh
from what happened before um so for
example in in particular settings like
um schools you know everybody's so
concerned about what's gonna happen you
can't keep
children off um schools uh forever it's
very damaging um
you know i've got three children at
different school ages
ages at home um it's devastating for
everybody but what is the plan
you know when you start you know sending
you know the school open to everybody
um everybody what's what is the plan to
try and reduce transmission we know now
that children
transmit um the virus even though very
luckily they don't get it
uh badly so um so we need to um look at
that
um and this is the time to plan that the
time is not when we come out end of
february or march or
whatever time the time is now to say
we've got these solid plans and we know
what we're doing when when the
restrictions are relaxed
and dr rowan it is of course uh very
easy for journalists like me to have an
ill or
uneducated puppet government advisers
even politicians through covert 19 but
we have to admit
you know everyone has been learning as
they have gone mistakes will undoubtedly
have been made
you know innocently in in good faith all
of that said
i mean even sir patrick concedes that at
times and this goes directly to your to
your brief at the university of
southampton but at times the messaging
has really not been on point and that
will have contributed to some of the
problems that you were just mentioning
yes absolutely agree again the messages
the messaging needs to be
very clear not confusing when we're
you know asking people to do things we
need to justify
where we're asking why we're asking and
also we need to
um the messaging needs to include um the
reality of the situation i mean for
example
um most of the messaging focuses on
debts
as the only bad outcome you know from uh
getting code 19 and we know now that
it's not and we know that illness and
potentially
um you know we will end up with a
mountain of chronic illness because of
long covert
um and you know that is not i i still
think that's not been communicated
um clearly to everybody the risk is that
even if you're younger
and you know have no pre-existing
conditions that there is
a chance that you will end up being ill
you know for a while from covet 19.
um that needs to be clear and also you
know we we've had a recent study
for example which was quite concerning
that uh you know people who were
discharged
from hospital after having copic 19 have
a
high rate or you know death 12 of them
died you know in a follow-up period of
you know of an average of about four
months or a little bit more
and actually 29 of them got readmitted
they had higher um you know risk of
having
cardiovascular disease uh they had
higher risk of having kidney disease
uh diabetes so this is um i think is not
still not being communicated clearly as
well about you know
these are the risks it's not just death
it's also illness
um well let's turn to uh professor
almond visiting professor of
microbiology at the university of oxford
also
advisor to the vaccine task force
professor it's really good to have you
on this morning and
understandably there is a degree of
concern at the moment that these
about the the vaccine and its efficacy
the data emerging from israel uh in the
past
24 hours and of course the changing of
the scheduled con
the scheduled second injection we had uh
sir patrick
defended the delay of of the second dose
of the fisa vaccine
are you entirely sanguine about that i'm
reasonably comfortable obviously it
deviates
from the recommendations of
manufacturers who developed it to be
given
as two doses with the spacing that they
investigated
but we know that for many vaccines that
space between the two vaccines is not
really a critical factor
and can be significantly longer so
on the one hand you can vaccinate more
people if you don't give a lot of people
two doses before others get any
on the other hand of course there is
that period
before you're completely protected which
is being extended by
the delay to the second vaccine now so
patrick talked about whether
that first dose is really effective and
of course we are all looking at what's
happened in
in israel um and he suggested that one
dose might not be enough to prevent
transmission and i think that's a
reasonable cautionary
position to take however i would be a
bit more optimistic
and think that one dose is likely to uh
perhaps not prevent transmission
completely but certainly contribute to
the reduction of the r number
uh if you're vaccinated even once you're
likely to shed a little less virus
for shorter periods if you do catch it
you're less likely to be seriously ill
that reduced shedding and shorter
duration of shedding
all contributes to the um to the
lowering of the r number
and therefore the ongoing spread will be
curtailed
the other comment i would say and this
was picked up by your technical
correspondent
um i think we have to be very uh aware
that this virus might change
and escape the vaccine-induced immunity
and that we might be in for a flu-like
situation
in the future however again let's not be
overly pessimistic
there are many viruses that we do
control with with virus
with vaccines that don't show this level
of change and mutation
flu does but mumps measles rubella polio
they don't they don't show the variation
we control them very effectively with
with vaccine we don't have to change the
vaccine on a seasonal basis
and in the past coronaviruses have not
been
uh let's say famous for their ability to
change
as in as rapid away as as flu does and
as hiv does
so at this point yes we have to be
cautious we have to prepare for the
possibility of change
but i don't think we need to be overly
pessimistic in our messaging to the
public
that you know it's inevitable that we'll
have to have vaccinations for years to
come and the virus will change
i don't see that as inevitable at this
point it's a possibility
but perhaps to my mind they're not
really the likeliest possibility
certainly not an inevitability and we
won't dwell too much on this but but if
it is the case that a new variant
it requires a new vaccine in terms of
the production of that vaccine
are we all the way back to to square one
do they ultimately have to
start the process again or or is there
work that can be built upon to speed up
the process
certainly we're not back to square one
what what the world has changed in the
last year
big time in the vaccine business and the
vaccine industry
uh we've it's turned out to be fairly
straightforward to design a vaccine
against covid and we're seeing different
designs with pfizer with astrazeneca
with valniva with the russians and with
the chinese
the thing that's been lacking is the
capacity to produce
these vaccines made with these types of
technology
at great scale and that's the thing
that's taking the time
now if if this had been a flu virus
we had the capacity there already and
because we make seasonal flu vaccines we
could have
simply switched into those factories
with that
equipment those supply chains and made a
lot of
uh pandemic flu vaccine very quickly
we'd have had billions of doses by
the autumn certainly uh now
we've built this capacity uh and if if
there is a change we can
react much more quickly next time we
have to that would be i'm sure that
would be something that will be
warmly welcomed by everyone watching
this morning professor
we we have a finite amount of time and i
do want to bring in dr daniel brydon
um vice dean of the faculty of intensive
care medicine
um up in sheffield um dr bryden and
we heard at the very end of our
interview i thought we should have
probably asked
sir patrick how he has been coping and
he says you know look
nhs staff are having a far tougher time
of it than i am
i'm certain you'd agree with that yes um
i think the fact that people perceive
that intensive care units up and down
the country are coping doesn't mean that
we've actually
not been overwhelmed because we have and
i think at some point patrick
sir patrick used the phrasal hands to
the pump and that's what it has been
it's been a significant effort
um nhs staff have been transferring
patients across the country for critical
care
we've been using other staff groups to
help us deliver care
and intensive care nurses have been
looking after significantly more
patients than they normally would do
so it's an adjustment of the term coping
i think really
given given that which we heard from sir
patrick about the fact you know there
may will be some restrictions come
winter that covered in some form or
another is going to be with us
for quite a long time what do we need
to do then we need to start planning for
now
in terms of the staffing within
intensive care
with within the health service in
general anyone who's been working on the
front line must have been having
having a tough time of it that's not
coming to an end any time soon so
what needs to be done right now to
ensure that when the pressure on the on
the gas is taken off just a little bit
that we can make sure that our
healthcare professionals are fine and
dandy
well you're quite right that what's
happening at the moment will still have
an ongoing effect
in many intensive care units well into
the spring and then
we will have to start thinking about uh
planning for the future and
and significantly putting focus on staff
health and staff well-being
um i i think at the present we are very
much focusing on the delivery of
care to patients and we know that our
staff are highly professional
but when we have systems in place for
planning how we deal
with um covid and other infectious
illnesses going forward
we will have to build into that means of
making sure that our staff are supported
and are resilient and able
to keep working and when things get
tough
um dr pride i'm afraid we have to leave
it there indeed i wish to thank all of
our guests on the programme this morning
professor callum semple from the
university of liverpool professor
jeffrey ahmad
from oxford university dr danielle
brydon from sheffield university of
sheffield and indeed dr
nistrin alwan from the university of
southampton
really appreciate your time today
and that brings us to the end of this
special show that
question and answer session on
coronavirus with the government's
chief scientific advisor sir patrick
valence you can find all the highlights
of that on the sky news mobile app
or indeed our twitter feed in the
meantime do stay tuned as it is a
big day in the united states and after
the break we'll be talking about the
inauguration
we'll be showing you donald trump's
final farewell plus i'm going to be
joined by rory bremner
to take a quick look back at the
president's tumultuous
time in office
america is divided
[Music]
today from 2 on sky news
you